bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 9
décembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
votre actualité locale
comme chaque jour entourés de nos
invités mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction commence tout de suite
avec les titres de cette édition la fête
des lumières célébrée en ce moment par
la communauté juive selon la tradition
se produisit le miracle de la fiole
d'huile permettant aux prêtres du temple
de faire brûler pendant huit jours une
quantité d'huile à peine suffisante pour
une journée nous reviendrons sur cette
tradition et le sommet mondial de
l'environnement n'est pas encore
terminée à paris mais nous ferons un
premier bilan avec le groupe local de
greenpeace l'organisation attend
maintenant des actes après les
déclarations et puis nous verrons
comment les communes se prépare pour
noël en se fournissant ce sapin auprès
des pépiniéristes
retour également sur le marché de
montigny le bretonneux et pour commencer
cette information le bras de fer entre
formations politiques se poursuit autour
de la future gouvernance de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au 1er janvier
cinq nouvelles communes vont intégrer la
casse qui est actuellement c'est le
nombre d'élus accordés à l'opposition
qui divise ainsi la gauche a décidé de
ne pas siéger ce soir à l'ultime séance
du conseil de la communauté de communes
de l'ouest parisien qui comprend plaisir
les clayes-sous-bois et villepreux
elle dénonce une place trop importante
réservée à la majorité dans le futur
ensemble conseiller municipal ps au clae
nicolas hué parle d'opacité et de manque
de transparence présidente de la
communauté de communes de l'ouest
parisien
joséphine coltman berger des
républicains lui répond qu'il se trompe
de combat
elle évoque une fusion purement
technique et dénonce une attitude
politicienne pendant l'entre-deux tour
de ces régionales
et tout comme les chrétiens avec noël la
communauté juive a dans la période de
fin d'année
un grand moment festif qui réunit toute
la famille
à nokia ou encore la fête des lumières
elle a été célébrée ce lundi soir sur le
parvis de la gare de montigny le
bretonneux fanny bourdillon étaient sur
place
jaz un missile la beauté nous bailly
même base de manas amen
c'est en musique et en danse que
montigny le bretonneux a fêté à nuuk 1
ce lundi soir appelée aussi la fête des
lumières
elle a une portée symbolique très fort
pour les juifs la coutume veut que l'on
allume une bougie par jour de fête il
habite chaque année d'allumer pendant
huit jours huit bougies chaque jour où
une bougie de plus nous bougie
supplémentaire
ce soir c'est la deuxième meilleure soir
c'était la première bougie fait ce qui
va se passer c'est une réunion justement
une manifestation pour pouvoir allumer
cette deuxième bougie tous ensemble afin
d'ajouter d'aligner de la lumière afin
d'éclairer un peu plus justement cette
obscurité qui arrivent huit jours de
festivités où l'occasion est aussi de se
régaler de beignets en référence aux
biens khl de lui tran otaniens aussi du
morimont en abrutis veut dire éducation
donc si on fait beaucoup d'enfance une
fête en famille il y avait coutume de
manger des choses halimi le retrait
puisque cette année accepterait répond
que c'est fait avec l'accueil du lot
temple donc c'est pour ça que la raison
pour laquelle nous avons des beignets
c'est la coutume de manger des beignets
et donc puisqu'il ya des enfants bien
sûr se réunir dans la joie avec un peu
dans la bataille des pop corn
toujours dans la tête cette année la
fête des lumières avait une résonance
particulière après les attentats du 13
novembre et ceux de janvier qui ont
notamment frappé la communauté juive
d'une soirée en ce soir de fête et je
crois que face au terrorisme il faut
répondre
comment vit habituellement on aime
s'amuser on aime la joie et bien
démontrons que malgré tout ce qui se
passe on est toujours présent ici à
voter dès à luca et symbole de lumière
sur l'obscurité mais aussi plus
largement de la paix sur la guerre et
nous accueillons ce soir en plateau
trois militants greenpeace et xavier a
cessé le cunin étiré darabont soir à
vous et merci d'être venus alors vous
êtes ici ce soir car l'antenne locale de
greenpeace de versailles organise une
soirée de bilan de la coop 21 à
versailles le vendredi 11 décembre
prochain c'est l'occasion donc de
décrypter la coop 25e' de rouleur en ce
moment même au bourget en france
alors voilà n'est pas encore finie quel
bilan vous en faites justement à
quelques jours de sa fin mais déjà on va
peut-être faire un petit rappel de ce
qu'est la coop 21 donc la coop 21 c'est
la 21e conférence des parties organisées
par l'onu
donc il y en a eu vingt-et-une une par
an depuis la première en 1995 à berlin
et c'est la réunion de 196 partie donc
196 gouvernement qui en gros vont
essayer de trouver des solutions aux
dérèglements climatiques
en ce qui concerne les gens n'ont pas
encore le bilan en fait puisque les
négociations sont encore en cours il ya
un texte qui doit être texte quasi
finale qui devrait selon nous ce que
demande de greenpeace en fait c'est de
rester sous 2 degrés c'est d'avoir 100%
de renouvelables en 2050 et ainsi de
suite après après on a l'impression
certain nombre de choses il faudrait que
ce soit un texte contraignant et
contraignant si juridiquement
voilà pour les états pour les états
justement les 196 qui sont présents à la
coop 21 pour justement atteindre ses
objectifs de rester sous l'augmentation
de 2 degrés donc là le texte aujourd'hui
est en cours de finalisation avec la
traduction juridique et linguistique
donc
ça se fait en ce moment là on n'a pas vu
les dernières modifications
on espère qu'il serait contraignant mais
on a des doutes on l'aimé à deux jours
de la fin en fait les grands sujets ne
seront pas réglés on ne sait pas si on
va sera sous 2 degrés on ne sait pas si
les financements seront des financements
seront débloqués on ne sait pas si le
texte contraignant donc aujourd'hui rien
n'est réglé à deux jours de la fin on
est un peu vous attendez plus d'eau plus
de réponse le plus rapidement à mettre
déjà dans le texte donc à la villa vers
la dernière version qu'on a pu voir il
n'y avait pas de mention d'énergies
fossiles et où énergies renouvelables
donc alors que le giec dit que pour
limiter l'augmentation de la température
du réchauffement climatique
il faudrait laisser 80% des énergies
fossiles sous le sol il y avait d'autres
sesay peut-être abordé qui n'ont pas été
assez la mise en avant dans cette coop
21 d'autres sujets bah disons que la
problématique du climat général on parle
beaucoup beaucoup du climat on parle
beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie mais on
parle assez peu par exemple
d'agriculture c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est à greenpeace nous tient à
coeur
heureusement rare de deux problématiques
on a de la déforestation mais de façon
plus qui sont des problèmes en dehors du
climat en fait en quelque sorte
enfin c'est tout ça est lié mais je veux
dire des problèmes en tant que tel et il
faut arrêter enfin peut-être parlé un
petit peu moins de toujours réduire tout
est chiffré enfin tout ça c'est quand
même une attitude un peu global à avoir
on va seulement voilà quand vingt
restent un petit peu obscur haut niveau
à des enjeux vous qu'on pourrait bien
noter enfin qu'il est du devoir des
goûts des devoirs des gouvernements de
faire ça qu'est ce que vous lui
reprochez justement à cette cause en
tant qu est ce qu elle aurait dû être
selon vous il y aurait d'autres choses
faire intervenir d'autres acteurs pour
soit plus efficace parce qu'on peut
reprocher déjà c'est le
les sponsors de la coque d'un terrain
qu'ils sont qui se présentent comme des
solutions aux problèmes alors quels sont
les problèmes
j'avais donc edf et angie par exemple
donc angie c'est 4% de renouvelables sur
toutes ses activités et donc c'est un
problème en soi et le se présente comme
une solution a signalé fossé est par
exemple on dit que la cap 21 est
organisée au bourget vous trouvez ça
aussi choquant l'aéroport du bourget
c'est un matériau non non il fallait un
lieu
bon je vais peu importe mais le cas des
sponsors quand même très gênant et que
si je les fait que les parties civiles
n'est pas accès à certaines des
délibérations qui se font à huis clos de
ce que de ce qu'on a compris le laisser
sur le travail était fermé aux ong
c'est quand même un problème pour ceux
qui alors que la population est
clairement la peau la première visée par
tous et on a aussi l'impression qu'il ya
plus de lobbyistes en fait que deux ong
dans les couloirs il ya justement le 28
novembre dernier à versailles un
rassemblement anti coptes le 21 avec
donc des artistes de notre dame des
landes
vous y étiez qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé que vous pensez de cette
initiative
alors déjà on y était en tant que
citoyen en tant que greenpeace et on
sait combien c'est quand même fort ben
non ils sont partis comme 21 c'est comme
ça ça c'était accepter leur
rassemblement voulue c'est
l'indiscipliné s'est justement
l'omniprésence de ces multinationales
qui sponsorise qui sont qui sont
présentes partout au bourget au grand
palais avec l'exposition solutions comme
21 et donc quand on voit tous ces
acteurs la présence est difficile de
croire qu'un accord va aboutir
oui je sens et puis reprendre le sujet
de notre dame des landes en plaine comme
21 c'est quand même très faible signal
oui vous aurais préféré d'autres
solutions peut-être des ong engagées
dans l'accord inter parce qu'il faut
aussi proposer des solutions avec eux
forcément la commentaires ne plaît pas à
tout le monde
bah oui que le plus d'acteurs qui soit
qu'est ce que j'aurais aimé que le
gouvernement fasse appel avons par
exemple à greenpeace
les omci fonds sont au bourget mais
elles sont là l'occasion on les laisse
pas vraiment s'impliquer elles sont là
un petit peu on a l'impression pour le
décor et on leur demande elles donnent
leur avis et de temps en temps mais s'il
ya des sessions qui se déroulent sans
elle c'est sûr que c'est difficile de
d'ivoire quelque chose de positif et de
complètement transparent elles font pas
partie du négoce n'est pas fermée c'est
ce que les citoyens enfin les français
n'ont jamais en général sont assez
impliqués dans cette coque 21 selon vous
quand vous discutez avec les gens que
vous aller vers eux c'est vraiment un
sujet qui mobilise les jeunes les
personnes plus âgées ou est ce que les
français passent un petit peu à côté de
ce sujet là c'est difficile à dire ce
qu'on voit vraiment où des gens qui sont
fiche complètement d'autres qui sont
impliqués mais notamment par exemple le
week-end dernier à montreuil avait le
sommet citoyen pour le climat il y avait
beaucoup de monde donc avec beaucoup d
ong présentes pour présenter ce qu'elle
juge être les vraies solutions face au
climat
face au genre réchauffement climatique
et il y avait beaucoup de monde donc ça
ça ça laisse penser que de plus en plus
de gens s'y intéressent la wii aurait vu
3000 quand même trois mille visiteurs
donc c'est ça montre quand même une
certaine
et selon vous sur quoi il faut insister
pour voilà qu'il est peut-être une prise
de conscience parce que finalement c'est
un sujet qui concerne la touriste est
plate
je pense qu'il faut que les gens se
rendent aux consciences prennent de
conscience en fait du fait qu'ils sont
en fait
impliqué et que le réchauffement
climatique en fait va avoir des impacts
sur leur vie sur l'économie sur beaucoup
de choses et je pense que les gens ne
sont pas assez conscients de ça encore
disponibles à port saint louis on tracte
on informe les gens c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que le vendredi 11 décembre
on fait des réunions d'information à
versailles il ya un grand rassemblement
à paris samedi justement un citoyen
comment cela va un petit peu se passer
vous appeler les gens à venir participer
oui fait ça me dit et ce sera voilà un
rassemblement qu'est ce qui va se passer
un petit peu pour ceux qui souhaitent
eux ça ne peut pas encore tout dire
parce que nous même on sait pas encore
comment tout va se passer exactement
avec l'état d'urgence il ya eu des tas
de choses qui ont dû être annulés
repenser king donc le mieux c'est pour
ceux qui sont intéressés c'est de taper
des douze points paris sur internet et
de suivre un peu comme les choses en
s'organiser mais il y aura un
rassemblement est le message du
rassemblement en fait c'est qu'on ne
laisse pas la commune un terme aux
politiques et c'est que c'est la société
civile qui auront le dernier mot alors
justement vous vous organisez donc la
soirée le vendredi 11 décembre donc
soirée post débat post comme 21 il ya
donc qu'est ce qu'on va faire après
justement ces appâts après la coop 20
ans que tout commence selon vous puisque
tu as tu sais tout continue oui parce
que on veut pas dire que ça a commencé à
la coop 21 c'est quand même la 21e il
serait temps de faire quelque chose et
voilà ça continue parce que clairement
on est quand même un petit peu
suspicieux sur les résultats qui vont
qui vont sortir de cette coop et puis de
toute façon c'est un sujet qui concerne
directement les citoyens donc c'est
quelque chose qui a toujours appartenu
aux citoyens qui leur appartient
toujours
il faut absolument continuer à se
mobiliser et faut une prise de
conscience heures
qu'ils soient pas seulement passagère
parce qu'on en parle dans les médias
rejoint bien sûr c'est plus ça va plus
loin alors je le rappelle donc le
vendredi 11 décembre à 19h30 à la maison
de quartier de porchefontaine à
versailles donc la soirée débat post
comme 21 donc voila vous inviter tout le
monde à s'y rendre pour s'informer
débattre avec vous merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur notre bateau d'avoir répondu à
nos questions si messi est le meilleur
apprenti de france cette année vient de
voisins-le-bretonneux vous en nous en
parlions la semaine dernière
gwendal a rapporté lundi la finale
nationale qui a confronté médiers
meilleur jeune de l'année étudiants au
centre de formation ferrand à jouy en
josas gwendal et ton apprentissage à la
ferme de voisins c'est dans ce
restaurant gastronomique de
l'agglomération qu'il a pu faire ses
armes
il sera notre invité mercredi prochain
avec son maître d'apprentissage romain
dit qu'elle est il y a un an
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines approuvé le pld le plan local
de déplacement
ce plan concerne tous les modes de
déplacements véhicule personnel
transports en commun mais aussi les
modes actifs que sont la marche ou
encore le vélo il hier la communauté
d'agglomération rassembler les divers
acteurs comme le stif le conseil
départemental où les communes pour tirer
un premier bilan on fait le point ce
soir avec mélanie poker bonsoir à
mélanie siens il sent flore alors ce
plan local de déplacement est un long
projet de la communauté d'agglomération
le premier pld a été approuvé en 2003 et
s'inscrit dans le pdf le plan de
déplacements urbains d'île de france
celui ci prévoit notamment de réduire de
20% les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2020 la case qui réalise
actuellement un bilan carbone du pld
dont les résultats devraient être connus
à la fin de l'année écoutez maylis
laurier la responsable services nouveaux
usages des mobilités de la communauté
d'agglomération ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui dans les déplacements
c'est de dire vous avez un bouquet de
mode de transport ans les québécois
appellent ça le cocktail transport mais
on vous offre un panel de solutions et
suivant le moment lors de la journée un
moment donné c'est la voiture qui la
plus efficace
le matin pour aller au travail c'est
sûrement les transports collectifs entre
milliers de le vélo c'est très bien
alors les saint quentinois les saint
quentinois effectue chaque jour 500
milles à déplacement ce qui représente 3
5 déplacements
jour et par personne quelles sont leurs
modes de transport privilégié mélanie
corps sans surprise c'est la voiture qui
la plus utilisée on le voit bien chaque
matin et chaque soir
ça représente 51 % des déplacements les
modes actifs eux représentent 31% et le
troisième mode ce sont les transports en
commun avec 15 % d'utilisateurs
on écoute à nouveau maylis fleurier on
est en termes d'augmentation des usages
aujourd'hui on est sûr on est constant
on perd pas d'usagé on en gagne pas on
pense qu'on va en gagner quand réussir à
réaliser les projets d'aménagement
faveur des bus par exemple sur la rd 912
pour aller avec le saint pierre
l'aménagement entre la gare de trappes
et la gare de la verrière des lignes de
bus ont été renforcées comme la 463 qui
relie elancourt à montigny et la 475 qui
permet de partir d'elancourt pour se
rendre à la porte d'orléans
la première a vu sa fréquentation
augmenter de 21% entre 2012 et 2014 et
pour la seconde c'est plus de 80 3% pour
l'année 2016 ce seront les lignes 415 et
439 qui seront renforcés alors l'un des
axes du bel et c'est aussi à
l'information auprès des usagers avec un
guide de la mobilité dans la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines des écrans
présente les horaires à des bus et la
localisation des arrêts soit la gare
routière paul delouvrier celle des prés
où la station souterraine et ça va se
développer sur le réseau plus
généralement mes plantes parce que d'ici
juin 2016 158 des soc 17 sans arrêt
présent sur la caisse qui seront équipés
de bandes d'information cbl indiqueront
les prochains passages de bus aux abris
ou au peuple et ce sont les arrêts non
protégés huit bornes sont déjà en place
sur les 414 on le voit l'image
elle relie montigny le bretonneux à la
gare de trappes didier blanchet et
directeur de ski bus il nous explique le
principe il ya deux types de
l'indication il ya des indications en
temps réel des deux prochains passage
des autobus et il ya une information à
caractère plutôt exploitation
s'il y a des difficultés liées à une
congestion de circulation s'il ya un
accident un feu
dans une commune hélas le régulateur qui
sera positionnée au siège social de
l'entreprise qui mise pour délivrer un
message pour tout ou partie des points
d'arrêts concernés par pas recette
impact sur la circulation alors en terme
de déplacement de transport on a souvent
tendance à pas pensé voiture ou encore
transport en commun mais il ya aussi les
modes actifs c'est-à-dire la marche à
pied ou le vélo et le pld cherche là
aussi à les développer notamment du côté
des cyclistes des itinéraires ont été
mes aménager ou sont en cours
d'aménagement
l'accent a été mis notamment sur la
sécurité des traversées de grands axes
de carrefour dangereux et des services
vont être mis en place ce que nous
explique miles lauriers c'est aussi le
projet de vélo station gare de
saint-quentin où là on va apporter du
stationnement sécurisé des vélos en
location de la réparation avec un
atelier donc accompagner le
développement du vélo ci par les
services pas juste par l'infrastructure
le pld concerne aussi la sécurité
routière la sécurisation des piétons les
transports de marchandises ou encore le
stationnement des véhicules
donc pour ceux qui voudraient se
renseigner en profondeur sur le plan
local
le document est disponible sur le site
internet de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
merci beaucoup mélanie est maintenant un
tout autre sujet nous allons parler noël
il va orner votre salon pendant
plusieurs semaines certains le choisit
son synthétique et d'autre le préfère au
naturel donc parlons bien évidemment du
fameux sapin de noël cette décoration
emblématique servant à souligner une
tradition païenne
al'approche défaite les municipalités
aussi passent leur commande dans la
commune de bazoches par exemple c'est
une tradition à laquelle on ne déroge
pas william el est patrick jacques de
dixmude
cela fait plus de dix ans que daniel
barbier fournit des sapins pour la
commune de bazoches ce pépiniériste de
la vallée de chevreuse permet à ses
clients de choisir leur sapin dans sa
plantation
aujourd'hui daniel barbier prépare sa
commande à livrer pour la commune
plusieurs petits sapins mais surtout un
grand norman de six mètres de haut qui
ornera la place de l'église à 4 m quatre
médecins quand on passa dans les filets
donc c'est quand même peu mais la passe
et si m enfin un entonnoir beaucoup plus
gros donc on l'est on attache avec de la
corde assez solide surtout dans le bas
et puis après surtout faire attention
pas casser la tête
le transport c'est l'étape la plus
délicate de l'opération coût total 1000
euros pour le maire de bazoches ces
frais sont indispensables pour ce
village de 600 habitants
une dépense qui est planifié tous les
ans dans son budget
on est sur un budget global d'un million
d'euros un petit million d'euros là on
parle de 1000 euros
mille 15 cents selon les années parce
qu'on réutilise le matériel de l'année
dernière notamment les guirlandes bien
évidemment toute la décoration et même
si les prix augmentent un petit peu les
sapins on pourra quand même se les payer
encore quelques années j'espère le sapin
arrivé tout le monde met la main à la
pâte pour le dressage le maire et ses
adjoints s'occupe personnellement du
montage et des décorations qui
illumineront le petit village jusqu'à la
fin des fêtes
et il a failli être annulée mais
heureusement finalement il a bien lu le
jeu il a bien eu lieu je parle bien sûr
du marché du traditionnel marché de noël
de montigny le bretonneux du 4 au 6
décembre pendant trois jours plus de
sens plus de 15000 visiteurs sont venus
profiter de la 24e édition de ce rendez
vous qui réunit ses 54 exposants de
produits alimentaires et 73 artisans
sephora dahmani et patrick jacques de
dixmude samedi dernier 11 heures
inauguration de la 24e édition du
traditionnel marché de noël de montigny
le bretonneux un marché apprécié pour
son atmosphère festive et la fidélité
des exposants qui reviennent chaque
année
comme michel henry depuis 17 ans voyez
une clientèle très fidèle et un à la
fois pour la qualité d'exposant
l'accueil ce que je vous ai dit
précédemment et aussi pour la fidélité
on va dire des exposants alors fidélité
des exposants et fidélité aussi des
gueux la clientèle c'est une bonne
synergie nous venons tous les ans
acheter
ce cantal vieux et les petits chèvres et
comme on est très contents revient
régulièrement plus de 15000 visiteurs
sont venus profiter des créations
originales et gourmandises proposées par
les 54 exposants de produits
alimentaires et des soixante treize
artisans présents pour l'occasion les
villes jumelées étaient également
associés à ce rendez vous qui a bien
failli ne pas se faire en raison du
contexte national
suite aux événements on s'est tous posé
les questions si on devait va tenir des
manifestations populaires
et aujourd'hui quand je vois tous les
exposants heureux d'être ici remonter
dix ils ont parcouru des centaines de
kilomètres pour être là et quand je vois
le nombre de visiteurs présents
je crois que nous avons pris la bonne
décision va très bien comme d'habitude
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait la route on
espérait bien que sa guerre qu'il aurait
lieu malgré tous les évènements entre le
père noël la pêche à la ligne et la
piste de ski de fond artificiel petits
et grands ont une impression de vacances
à la montagne
tout au long des trois jours du marché
et pour la troisième année consécutive
le réseau century 21 france organisé sa
collecte de jouets en faveur des
familles défavorisées la soirée de
remise des jouets aux associations a eu
lieu mardi 8 décembre
avec cette année un record avec plus de
quatre mille jouets collectés au mois de
novembre
la croix rouge française et
l'association enfance et partage
pourront donc garnir les sapins des
enfants démunis de la commune
toutes les familles de trappes étaient
invités à cette fête ainsi que les
commerçants et chefs d'entreprise qui
ont participé à l'opération
houria et l'edge directrice de l'agencé
century 21 de trappes a insisté sur
l'importance de cet événement pour les
habitants le but c'est en premier plan
c'est de
d'avoir des fonds pour qu'on puisse
entamer la période hivernale comme il se
doit et aussi le but est ainsi de vend
des vêtements de bonne qualité à un prix
défiant toute concurrence
c'est à dire à un euro symbolique et le
3 décembre dernier la proposition de loi
de françois de mazières députée divers
noir de verteuil de son homologue serge
grouard de l'est républicain de loire et
discutés devant l'assemblée nationale a
été rejetée signée par 70 députés celle
ci visait à faciliter la rénovation des
casernes de gendarmerie en utilisant les
crédits de l' agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine des casernes vétuste
et délabré comme la cité delpal de
satory construite en 1935 est
aujourd'hui proche de l'insalubrité
satory constitue la plus importante
implantation de gendarmes en france avec
la présence de six escadrons mobiles et
du célèbre jgm soit 1500 militaires qui
vivent dans des conditions précaires on
écoute kevin crombez au micro de sephora
namani la cité delpal donc une caserne
bâtie dans les années 30 si je ne me
trompe pas le
il ya plusieurs problèmes majeurs dont
notamment le vitrage qui fait 2 mm
d'épaisseur qui enfin au niveau
isolation thermique
ce n'est rien c'est du papier c'est
dommage que ces coupures d'eau chaude ce
vitrage et autres deviennent une
véritable habitude et que ça rentre dans
le sens commun alors que si on le
secteur civil jamais ça passerait dans
le sens dans le sens commun c'est bien
dommage c'est la fin de cette édition
merci nous avoir suivis tout de suite
vous avez rendez vous avec sephora
namani pour une nouvelle édition du
magazine q est ce que votre magazine
culturel quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain à 18 heures pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal en direct je
vous souhaite donc une excellente soirée